I think my favorite thing about being an
astronaut is being a part of something
so much bigger than just me I was born
and raised on a farm in Iowa so grew up
in a very rural environment when I was
nine years old I saw Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin walk on the moon wasn't
until I graduated from high school that
they selected the first female
astronauts and so for me that's when it
became a transition from being a dream
to a goal and I joined NASA in 1986 I
applied for 10 years after I got my PhD
to become an astronaut before I was
lucky enough to be selected my most
recent expedition actually ran over nine
and a half months very special to get to
spend some extra time onboard the
International Space Station it's an
amazing laboratory where we conduct many
different scientific experiments I also
got to do four more spacewalks nothing
really beats going for a walk out in
space going on a spacewalk is really
special because you're in a spacesuit is
basically like a little spaceship built
for one person it's protecting me
thermally and pressure-wise from the
vacuum of space but what's most amazing
about the spacewalk is the view remember
we're going at 17,500 miles an hour 16
times around the planet every day so
we're seeing a sunrise and a sunset
about every 45 minutes as we go into the
Eclipse and come out into the Sun first
you see what we call the limb of the
earth and it's just this thin blue curve
of line just as the light of the Sun is
starting to come around the planet and
so alien to everything that we've grown
up with here on earth everything is
based on gravity everything and when you
get up there it's not anymore and I just
enjoyed the entire nine and a half
months a day in space starts off by
waking up then usually I'd go an
exercise we exercise about two and a
half hours a day and that's in order to
maintain our muscle strength on orbit we
have a tendency to lose both of those if
we don't
exercise and the day could be anything
we could be doing scientific research I
could be fixing the toilet Friday nights
we had a little tradition where we do
dinner in a movie everybody was kind of
into science theme so we watched
passengers and life lots of science
fiction movies that is one of the really
special things about working in space is
that every day is a little bit different
but I think a long-duration spaceflight
what's very special about it is it it
becomes home you you adapt to being in
zero gravity being able to move around
so easily is a real treat and once you
adapt to that it's it's hard to give it
up to come back to earth because gravity
really does suck during my first and
second missions there were numerous
women that came up to meet me onboard
the space station and in fact when I was
the female commander of the
International Space Station Pam Melroy
was commanding the shuttle that docked
to the space station so that was very
special to have two women commanders on
orbit at the same time I wasn't the
first female that happened to fly in
space and I've had lots of role models
along the way to help and guide me and
most importantly make me believe it's
possible
being able to inspire even one or two
children to do something they didn't
think they could do I would consider
that a big win for me